hey guys there's a live stream going on
right now where me PewDiePie and a few
other youtubers that you may know
running a charity livestream to raise
money for charity water and if you don't
know about charity water then please
click the link in the description below
to learn more about the current water
crisis that's going on across the globe
did you know that a billion people don't
have regular access to clean safe water
and that accounts for more deaths
especially in children than all the
violence and all the wars across the
globe it's a huge problem that needs a
huge solution so PewDiePie is trying to
raise 250 thousand dollars towards this
charity and that's a big number but just
$20 can make sure that one person
doesn't have to worry about clean water
ever again so please join us it's gonna
be lots of fun we're gonna be playing
lots of games there's gonna be special
guests so I hope you'll be there so
thanks for watching and I will see you
at the charity livestream bye bye
[Music]